كنت دائما اعتبر ان المراه تستطيع ان تشغل
كل المناصب هكذا تربيت في عائلتي قالوا لي
ما يستطيع ان يفعله الرجل تستطيع المراه
ان تفعله ايضا وبالنسبه لي لم يطرح هذا
الموضوع اي مشكله انا لست مناصره للحركه
النسويه انا اؤمن ان امراه تتمتع بالكفايه
يتم استعدادها من اجل رجل غير كفوف هو امر
مخزن ولكن اجد ايضا مخزيا تعين امراه اقل
كيف يتم من رجل فقط لانها امراه يجب ان
ناخذ في الاعتبار في كل مره معيار الكفايه
وما هي معادله الكفايه في كل رجل وامراه
مع المنصب المقترح من جانبي لم اعاني ابدا
من اي تمييز لكون امراه
هذه المساله ربما تطرح في شكل اكبر لدى
الرجال الذين يقولون في منافسه بينهم
عندما تم اختيار رئيسه للحزب الديكولي حزب
التجمع من اجل جمهوريه احد منافس قال لا
يمكن لامراه ان تكون في هذا المنصب ولكن
بعد ذلك تم تعيين امراه رئيسه للحزب كنت
اولا امراه تنتخب رئيس لبلديه مغيسا جلوز
بالقرب من بلده بياغيت ايضا قال منافس لا
يمكن ان تكون امراه رئيسه بلديه ولكن بعد
ذلك تم انتخابي وبغالبيه ساحقه مرات عده
عندما تم تعيينه وزيره للدفاع تفاجا
العسكريون ولكن الامور صارت على ما يرام
وبعد ذلك حفظته على علاقتي مع العسكريين
حتى الان